i think uh you know if we everything
starts with a thought i mean everything
that you do in your life you you have to
have a thought before you initiate an
action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits those memories are
actually causing them to think in the
past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences so then the moment they
recall the event or the they recall some
problem in their life they start feeling
unhappy they start feeling discouraged
they start feeling anxious
now thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being so we
could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is is that biology tends
to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain the nerve cells
that fire together wire together so all
of a sudden you start getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time those
thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so some people
would rather cling to the familiar than
take a chance in possibility so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place so you feel uncomfortable so it's
easier to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
re-mold the brain you can only attract
according to the frequency that you're
operating on
attraction is the secondary law the
primary law is the law of vibration
that's a that's a primary law of the
universe everything in this room is
moving
nothing rests this table's moving it
just appears to be still
the law of vibration decrees everything
moves nothing rests
well when you think you put you under a
frequency
you can only attract what's on that
frequency
you think about a person a lot just
concentrate on that personal from you
or you'll bump into them on the street
because you you're thinking about it
yeah the law of attraction takes over
you can attract to you what you're in
harmony with well when you set goals
you're going to see yourself already
there that's called a mindset
a lot of people talk about mindset they
don't understand what it is they set
their mind on the frequency that they
have to be in to attract what they have
to
attract and that's how the gold moves
into form you get emotionally involved
you're
so intellectually and emotionally
involved
the only problem is you don't have it on
the physical plane
yet
but it will manifest in time if i have a
picture of fear in my mind i'm afraid of
something my brain translates fear with
different chemicals stress hormones
cortisol norepinephrine
factors that affect immune system that
are called cytokines or histamine
so basically in a state of conscious
fear the brain releases chemistry that
complements fear that chemistry goes
into the body's blood and that changes
the behavior and the genetics of the
person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts
and people say oh that positive thinking
doesn't really work but that's not true
the best example of positive thinking in
a scientific study is called placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
this new pill and it's the brand new
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill so then you're left with
so what made me well it's not the sugar
pill it was the positive belief in that
sugar pill and how it's going to help
your life
so that's called placebo positive
thinking positive result unfortunately
most people don't recognize a more
important point
negative thinking is equally powerful
but it works in the opposite direction
so it turns out for example
less than 10 percent of cancer is even
connected to a family lineage 90 of
cancer just comes out of the blue so to
speak but the reality is no it's a
result of stress and negative thinking
so it's important point positive
thinking negative thinking equally
powerful because that's the level of
consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics
i just want to add a very important
point to this quantum physics is the
most valid science on this planet there
is no science that has been tested more
and verified more i guess so what's the
relevance because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of our lives the
simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are accepted and
brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life would i like to have the experience
that this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we can begin on the smallest level to
be aware of our thinking we can start to
make changes when we're talking about
energy there's the great law of
attraction of vibration
when things are on the same frequency
there are in resonance all right so
let's not think of the law of attraction
okay
as this thing that's like a magnet that
attracts because
if you were to take magnets and put
together you know positive and positive
it actually will repel it's positive and
negative that are in resonance and
attract
so when we're thinking about the law of
attraction i want you to skip the old
metaphysical
laws that you may have heard of or
explanations you heard of and i want you
to think about
resonance so for example if you ever
walked into a room
and not a word has been said and you
know something's wrong and you say
because you're feeling the vibration
you're feeling this something is wrong
your intuition is picking up the
vibration in the room and you know
something's wrong and you go hey what's
wrong and the people in the room go oh
nothing
and you go no no seriously what's wrong
well how do you know that something is
off
and the answer is because this thing
called our body and this thing called
our brain
is
and is energy vibrating at a certain
frequency and so when things are not
great we're emitting this frequency that
other
humans can feel we're picking it up with
our intuitive sensors in our brain
and through our field so when we think
about the law of attraction
we should actually be thinking about
am i in resonance right okay
energy that is on the same frequency
will resonate and attract so if you want
to understand the law of attraction
around wealth a relationship health
money are you in resonance
with that which is already here
see if you're thinking positive
but you're feeling negative if you're
thinking you know i want to double
triple quintuple my income but inside of
you you're thinking that you're not
smart enough not good enough not not
worthy enough then part of you is
vibrating at the here's what i want to
have be attract etc but if there's
another part of you vibrating at a
different frequency there is no harmony
there is no resonance there's chaos for
all of us you know and
we've been conditioned you know i mean
you were very fortunate because you you
had a
a childhood where
you were
mind was opened and you were opened and
your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing
is to open yourself to the possibility
that everything isn't the way it appears
to be
and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up at all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are
then you have the greatest opportunity
to really discover something incredible
how incredible you are
you know the people you surround
yourself with have a phenomenal impact
on your life i think it was carl meneger
from the medicare foundation one time
said
environment is more important than
heredity
the people we're surrounded by have a
greater bearing on our life and our
success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends
if the answer is yes you're already in
the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on our life and help
make us who we are have you ever spent
any time wondering how does everything
happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this
in fact at times it almost drives me
crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud grown and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're
greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up in here and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now some place the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
an exact way
not by chance but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states
actually asked dr warner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with a
precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i
get in harmony with the law now we're do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
[Music]
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now i've been doing that for the last
58 years i'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but i don't
understand them as well as i wanted to
or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here i'll have to talk
to you about this book
that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win
you ever notice that some people seem to
want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a failure at something and
it's dwelling they can't get over it
they just can't get over it or somebody
said something nasty to them they don't
want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you
i want you to think about this i'm not
going to talk about a lot about this
today because i don't think i have to i
just want to let you know that if you're
holding on to something that does not
serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation uh-uh it's
you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
you know the beautiful part about having
an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you you see the beautiful truth
is you've already got everything you
need inside
you don't have to get it
you don't have to follow the pattern
that our formal educational institutions
teach us
you don't have to read all the books
that's unnecessary
i think madame montessori put it very
well she said we should send a child to
school
as if they're an empty cup and we expect
them to fill the cup
she's the truth is the cup's already
full
school is to help draw what's already
there
you see you and i are god's highest form
of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will even come close to us
strange thing to know you and i are the
only creature on the planet that is
totally disoriented in our environment
all those other little creatures they're
completely at home in their environment
they blend in
we don't
we're totally disoriented
and that is because we have the ability
united of creating our own environment
now think of what that means
that means that you and i can literally
create the life we want
you know as i said when i first heard
that i did not believe it
but i knew the man that was giving me
the advice believed it and that man was
raymond douglas stanford one of my very
first mentors dr maxwell mulch wrote a
book back around 1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho-cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have
done a nose job or removed a terrible
scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate that we have
two images we have the one that's coming
back from the mirror
but we've got an inner image and that
inner self image is literally
controlling our life
you will find people that have a very
poor self-image or low self-esteem they
won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life
they don't like themselves
they don't know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago i had very poor self-image
i had low self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're god's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller
you'll stand a little straighter and you
know something you'll enjoy a whole lot
more of life if i want to do something
i find somebody that's already done it
and then i do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow
i um
i don't read novels
i don't watch movies
um
i'd watch documentaries or things like
that where i can learn
and
i'm only interested in
studying
something that can cause me to become
more of what i'm capable of being
see i think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with our life
and
that's all i want to do
i'm really good at what i do i could
walk by a person in the hall like that i
could tell them exactly what they're
like i could read their energy like a
book
everything goes on the inside shows the
outside see
we're gifted with with faculties of the
mind that the average person knows
nothing about you of intuition the will
reason imagination perception
memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life
we go through school never learn
anything about it
like you'll hear people say they have a
bad memory there's no such thing as a
bad memory everybody has a perfect
memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it
our
imagination your imagination is the most
magnificent he hill said it's the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force the world's ever known i
can use my imagination to project myself
into the future and bring the future
into the present and start living there
you work from the imagination you don't
work to it
you work from it backwards from the
result yeah although you cannot change
conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah
and it's a lack of understanding that's
causing all our problems we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
all the little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school and
we've never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch
our physical senses and we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you well you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are but it
really tells us where our mind was at
for a few minutes three weeks ago got
nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority i
like there's a saying on all of your
seminars on the tickets
if you have to borrow money for this
do it it may be the last time
you're doing it listen
when i when i read this
i owed everybody i knew money
but the guy that
told me he said don't clean officer for
somebody else do them for yourself and
he told me where i could buy a used
floor machine and some buckets and mops
it was going to cost 980
i mean i didn't know anyone would lend
me money because i never paid them back
not that i didn't want to i just never
had any money
well i searched and searched and
searched and i found a guy that lent me
a thousand dollars so when somebody
tells me they can't borrow money i know
that they haven't tried
i think anybody can borrow a thousand
dollars somewhere
and that's what i did
and i turned it into a multi-million
dollar organization
i sat down one day with my pen
in this business i said i'm going to
build a company that operates all over
the world we operate all over the world
so if you have to borrow money
borrow the money
but get into the business
actually do it see someone woke me up
that's all i want to do with someone
else what the man said to me the first
guy he said you can have whatever you
want
well you know they if you get thinking
that you can get out of the box that's
why you've been given an imagination to
get out of the box it's with your
imagination that you build images of
what you want and if you can build the
image you can do it you can hold it in
your head you can hold it in your hand
when we understand that
like i would imagine this goes out to a
lot of athletes
well they can they can have anything
they want they got to pay the price
and when doubt comes in kick it out you
can't afford the doubt
sandy gallagher is my business partner
love her
she is really good
she was going through a very tough time
personally
a number of years ago we were in phoenix
we were doing a seminar
i had to leave
catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave
could we get together maybe for a cup of
coffee
could you um
i want to talk to you and i said sure
so we went across the road to a coffee
shop
and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this
i said sure i didn't know what i was
going to tell her but i knew i'd tell
her something
so i said every day
i want you
to take a pen
and write down every morning write down
10 things you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it you're really
grateful
then i want you
to send love to three people that are
bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them
they've got nothing to do with it you're
thinking bad thoughts about them you're
putting yourself in a bad vibration send
love to three people that bother you
and then
take five minutes
and be quiet
just be perfectly quiet and asked for
guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day
she started to do it like that
everything changed
in fact
my assistant gina who's been with me
over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
gina i told her what i wanted within an
hour she had a pad printed at kinko's
and had it
the 10 things from one down to 10 you
know
send love to three people and bother you
be quiet for five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii with her
sister and her mother the next day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that it
changed every one of their lives
we give that out now in a lot of our
seminars and we train the audience to do
it
start every morning write 10 things that
you're grateful for
send love to three people who bother you
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
it's a winning form william james from
harvard said believe and your belief
will create the fact
all things are possible if you believe
well you know i studied for a long time
i started to study this book think and
grow rich and he talks about belief in
here he says you're not ready for what
you want until you believe you can get
it
i found that the
only two sources of reference we could
go to to find out anything about
yourself is science and religion
they all say you've got to believe
so i get figured out
how do you how do you believe
how do you change a belief
interesting subject because i'm going to
tell you something
your results are nothing but the
manifestation of your belief system
well our belief system of listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
re-evaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change
let me repeat that
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something
frequently if we re-evaluate a situation
our belief about it will change
i began re-evaluating who i was i
started to study i never stopped
studying and i found as i reevaluated i
had a much higher opinion of myself i
found out things about me that i would
have never believed if you had told me
the power that's locked up within us the
marvelous system we've got you know the
blood circulates through your veins
every 33 seconds through hundreds of
miles of passageway dying just like that
colors all the food in and all the
garbage out stop and think of the
central nervous system it's the most
complex electrical system in the world
and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you
we have awesome powers and it's all
based on what you believe how about you
right now i'm standing in the middle of
my library this is my favorite place you
know earl nightingale said if you
surround your mind with greatness some
of it's gonna rub off well hopefully
some of it is rubbed off on me i have
maybe three or four thousand books here
on the shelf they're all in alphabetical
order uh by author they're all
catalogued so i know where to find
something just like that i go by authors
more than the title of the book
do you know that
when i started studying these books i
really didn't know very much about
anything i had two months high school i
was 26 years old i had a bad work record
a bad attitude and and virtually no
experience
and you know in a relatively short
period of time my income went from 4 000
to 175 000 a year then it went over a
million you've got to wake up
you see
all we're ever going to get is awareness
we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got
we're god's highest form of creation
there's nothing on the planet that will
equal us
well
that's all we're that's all any of us
are after that's all the problems in the
world come from ignorance
that's the purpose of life overcome
ignorance develop awareness the only way
to overcome ignorance is through
knowledge and the only way to get the
knowledge is to study
most people they finish school close the
book saying i got it that's over i'm
never going to open another book as long
as i live
they're screwed it's all over napoleon
hill
in think and grow rich wrote an entire
chapter on decision
most people never make decisions they
have a difficult time with it why is
that
i think they have a difficult time
because their parents made decisions for
them until they were too old
and they never learned how to make them
you know the one thing that i did with
my kids i never made a decision for them
they didn't like it they'd say come on
don't do that to me i said no what do
you think you should do and i'd leave it
at that
decision making is a phenomenal concept
and you're going to find out as he
points out in here that successful
people make decisions very fast and they
change them very slow if and when they
change them at all and he said the
people that have difficulty in life make
their decisions very slow and then
change them fast and often
and you know decision making is a funny
thing you and i think on frequencies if
we can see a bunch of lines and we're
thinking on a frequency
and we're on this frequency here and we
say i'm going to do that
when this changes this is never going to
change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you got to get your mind up
there how do you get up there make the
decision be there and that's really what
you have to do the second you make a
decision you flip your brain onto a
different frequency and you start to
attract things to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision most people are waiting for
their life the change yes so they can
feel gratitude to feel abundance to feel
whole you know that's the old model of
cause and effect you know so if you're
living with emptiness you're living with
lack you're living with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life
and you're living by lack well lack is
going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's a scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind so your personality
literally yet is made up of how you
think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life
so then if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that
you begin to objectify your subjective
self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
would you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
[Music]
think about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits or hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted
everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality
you're not seeing it the way it is
you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are
blessing those centers and taking a
scoop and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy's
gonna move scott was going to follow the
path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage because of that
person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap
there's a release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and i let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this
for the grudge you were holding because
this feels too good
are you with me still now once that
heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing
1300 to 1400 different chemicals that
begin to restore and regenerate the body
the body start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending energy to the
brain the heart acts as an amplifier to
boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin when you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life and that's when
you're free now the practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
in the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said and she was an incredible
bliss when this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was she was
isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same way didn't pass to a
birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness think of your autonomic
nervous system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our systems a part of our
nervous system that functions behind the
scenes of our awareness and it regulates
body temperature and and hormones and
blood supply and blood sugar levels
in it and it happens without any uh uh
of our conscious mind
so
in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system and its job
is for
protection
from threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal and when
there's a danger to the gross anatomy of
the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses
this system is switched on automatically
and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources
for that threat or that danger to deal
with it and and when it's switched on
we don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down and all of these
systems switching on and turning on
is to be able to allow the body to adapt
to some threat in the outer world and
that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run
from the danger
to fight
and stay
or to freeze and hide and those are the
primary choices that we have created in
evolution and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on
and we as we've been saying for very
long for a very long time
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where utilizes nutrients and and
transports chemicals to cells and
metabolism goes up and and this is a
time for growth this is a time for
repair this is a time for restoration
and there's a delicate balance between
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy for growth repair
restoration there's no energy for
long-term building projects attitude
works a lot
if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful for
what
the good is in your life the more good
you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know somebody
gives you a present and you're or gives
me a present and i say oh my god i hate
that color and it doesn't fit and you
know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude well the simple
part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are accepted and
brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
[Music]
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to
it now i think this has been around
forever but for some reason in the last
20 years the universe has wanted this to
go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we can begin on the smallest level to
be aware of our thinking we can start to
make changes after they're done doing
the work they can go and tap on those
issues so sort of combine both together
you do the mirror work it brings up the
things that are bubbling or maybe you
can even tap in front of the mirror
maybe that'll be the next innovation and
tap and say affirmations in front of the
mirror you know yes
yes so do you want to do a little
tapping sure you know for the for the
crowd so
i know we did a little there you had a
little neck pain in the last couple days
so we did some tapping but we could
always do a little more yeah
so how how deep do you want to go
well how do
you want to take me
so let's for for people who weren't with
us private last couple sessions let's
talk about the neck pain and what was
going on and
um and our conversation it started as
some spasms yes it started as some
spasms that wouldn't go away
and i was feeling tremendous pressure
back here and down my neck
and uh i realized that this went back to
a time when i was five years old and
my stepfather used to hold my head under
water and he had his thumb in that
particular place
and
my thought was for some reason it's time
for me to let this go
and the thing is how to find out how to
do it because i wasn't doing very well
on it i was just pounding away at myself
i think that everything you think and
everything you speak goes out from you
into the universe and comes back to you
multiplied uh it's almost as though the
universe is listening to everything you
say and everything you think and saying
oh that's what they want
but most of the time we are talking very
negatively about ourselves we talk about
how awful we are we're not good enough
we can't get this we can't get that how
can the universe bring you anything good
if that's the way you're talking you
know so many people think that money is
the most important thing in the world if
they don't have money they would just
die
but that's not true
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live
air your air your breath your breath is
the most important thing that you have
the most precious thing if you didn't
take another breath you wouldn't last
three minutes and you'd never get out of
this room and yet we absolutely take for
granted that our next breath is there
look at us we're all in this room
breathing and i'm not saying don't
breathe there's not enough for me
we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us
has given us enough breath to last for
as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet has been put
here for us to play with
we have everything that we shall ever
need it's already here only we have to
know it and we have to trust it and we
have to acknowledge it
do you realize that there is more food
on this planet than people could
possibly eat
there's an incredible amount of food yes
it is true that there are people
starving
but the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count
the money is here now there are lots of
people who are very broke but the money
is here
there are billions of people on this
planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every dis
ease on this planet there is a plant
that'll cure it
everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life
and acknowledge the beauty and
magnificence of our own being the more
we find everything we need it just pops
up
i know that you've heard me say many
times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows beautifully i'm not
talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible
magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves you were born in pure love
all of you there's not one little baby
alive i that i know of that ever
criticizes its body or ever says my hips
are too big have you ever heard a baby
say that
[Applause]
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body
they rejoice in it and they love
themselves they love their toes they
love everything about themselves they
absolutely adore
they
express their feelings you know when a
baby is happy you know it when a baby is
angry the whole neighborhood knows it
they're never scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage
and they're wonderful and we were all
like that
got to remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little well the simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are accepted and
brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among
all the people or all the people that
are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we can begin on the smallest level to
be aware of our thinking we can start to
make changes after they're done doing
the work they can go and tap on those
issues so sort of combine both together
you do the mirror work it brings up the
things that are bubbling or maybe you
can even tap in front of the mirror
maybe that'll be the next innovation and
tap and say affirmations in front of the
mirror you know yes
yes so do you want to do a little
tapping sure you know for the for the
crowd so
i know we did a little there you had a
little neck pain in the last couple days
so we did some tapping but we could
always do a little more yeah
so how how deep do you want to go
well how do
you want to take me
so let's for for people who weren't with
us private last couple sessions let's
talk about the neck pain and what was
going on and
um and our our conversation it started
as some spasms yes it started as some
spasms that wouldn't go away
and i was feeling tremendous pressure
back here and down my neck
and uh i realized that this went back to
a time when i was five years old and
my stepfather used to hold my head under
water and he had his thumb in that
particular place
and
my thought was for some reason it's time
for me to let this go
and the thing is how to find out how to
do it because i wasn't doing very well
on it i was just pounding away at myself
to begin with you start by doing what we
call doing affirmations and that is
making positive statements about your
life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night uh
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights and the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life it can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do is to stand in front of a
mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting
and accepting yourself
or noticing that you reject yourself
when you're saying something positive
about yourself
so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and i know this
sounds far-fetched but it's amazing how
it works
you if you do a good general
positive statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you
you plant a seed and you expect it to
grow
you maybe plant three seeds just in case
you expect them to grow and you don't
wait two days and then dig in the earth
and say what's happening what's
happening you expect that thing to grow
because you know there's a law and a
process and the seed will grow if it is
in the right soil and it has the right
amount of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night
and and gratitude works a lot
i think we get we all get certain ahas
and that's when we've sort of learned
something we say oh okay
and then if we can keep that
what we've learned and practice it
then we've made another step and we can
move forward
yes it's a lifetime journey and we never
stop learning
i'm 80 and i'm still learning
though the lessons are easier now than
they used to be i like to think of that
when we start we have all these boulders
in front of us on our pathway and we
start to get the boulders out of the way
and you finally get to the point where
it's gravel
and gravel you can handle
you know and you can sweep gravel and
you can do things
so
and then occasionally there's an old
boulder
that rolls back into your bed
you think oh i thought i thought i had
that one but not completely
and and you know also i think that when
we learn lessons we think oh i've
learned that one it'll never happen
again i've done that and that's it
well how do you know you've done it
unless it comes by once more and see how
you react
have you really learned it is it really
nothing for you have you gone beyond
that or are you going to go right back
into the same old reaction
see we're never wrong
that's what we need to learn that we're
always doing the best we can with the
understanding and awareness and
knowledge we have at that moment because
you made it this far in a video i want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you're special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some powerful manifestation
techniques with bruce lipton check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i asked a question to
the universe which then my cells
answered i asked a question when i just
realized and owned i exist as a
field energy a spirit